- [Instructor] So let's
say I was preparing
to go on a long hike.
Besides packing water,
dressing for the weather
and mapping my route,
I'd probably also want to eat a snack
before leaving to make
sure I have enough energy
for the hike.
We as humans need food
to nourish our bodies.
But how exactly does
that food give us energy?
How does something like an
apple or a piece of chocolate
get converted into something
our bodies can use?
The answer to this question can be found
in a process called cellular respiration.
Which is how organisms get
their energy from food.
In other words,
cellular respiration
helps make life possible.
It's happening right now in your cells
and in mine,
in my little brothers pet hamster cells
and in the cells of the
tree outside the window.
It's providing all of us with the energy
that we need to function.
So let's dive into this process
to find out more about how it works.
Cellular respiration is a
series of chemical reactions
that happen in an organized
way inside our cells.
It's these chemical reactions that result
in an overall release of
energy that our bodies can use.
Although cellular respiration
involves many chemical
reactions, this entire process
for plants and animals
can be summarized here
by this equation.
On the left side of this
equation are the inputs;
Glucose, which is a type of sugar,
and oxygen.
Glucose comes from our
food and oxygen comes
from the air we breathe.
The right side of this
equation shows the outputs,
carbon dioxide and water.
The air in the middle shows
that during the process
of cellular respiration,
glucose and oxygen molecules
are are broken apart
and their atoms are rearranged
to eventually form
carbon dioxide and water.
This whole process releases energy,
similar to how firewood
releases energy as it burns.
Also, no atoms are lost
during cellular respiration.
You can see the same
number of each type of atom
on both sides of the arrow, for example,
six carbon atoms on both sides.
It's similar to how you could
take apart a brick house
and use those bricks to build
something else, like a bridge.
You're not throwing
away any of the bricks,
but instead you're creating
something new out of them.
So we know that cellular
respiration involves a series
of chemical reactions,
but where in the cell
do these steps happen?
To find out, let's walk
through the process together.
After eating, your food is broken down
into small molecules during digestion.
These small molecules
which include glucose
can enter your cells.
Then cellular respiration can begin.
The first set of chemical
reactions happen in the cytosol,
which is the jelly-like
fluid containing all
of the cells organelles,
and they involve glucose as an input.
The rest of the reactions
happen in mitochondria,
with oxygen as an input and carbon dioxide
and water as outputs.
Together, these chemical reactions result
in an overall release of energy.
It might be a little mind boggling
for you to think about how
the food we eat provides
the energy our bodies need
to carry out all of lives processes.
And I know it was for me.
After all, it's not every day
you take a bite of an apple
and wonder how that apple's molecules
are rearranged inside your body.
What's important to know though,
is that cellular respiration
is the way our cells get usable energy.
Through cellular respiration,
you and I get the energy that we need
to do the things we want to do,
including accomplishing our goals.
So, the next time you feel
proud of your yourself
for finishing a big hike
or acing your biology quiz,
make sure to thank your mitochondria.